GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED AS A.
SUBCOMMITTEE AND IT LOOKS LIKE.
.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY PRESENTERS SO
I'M GOING TO HAND. THE GAVEL
OVER.
CLICK HERE.
OKAY.
NMAP.
THAT WAS THE BANG OF THE GAVEL.
TO.
SO.
MADAM CHAIR.
WILL BE PRESENTING AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINE. BATTLING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
WOULD ESTABLISH AN OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AUDITS AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS. AND A CHIEF
AUDITOR TO LEAD THAT DEPARTMENTS
CHIEF AUDITOR WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE TO THE SECRETARY FOR
CONDUCTING AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
TO INCREASE EFFICIENCY IMPROVE
OPERATIONS AND REDUCE FRAUD
WASTE AND ABUSE.
.
BUT CHIEF AUDITOR WOULD ALSO BE
A POWDER EMPOWERED TO CONDUCT
INVESTIGATIONS UPON INFORMATION
FROM ANYBODY INCLUDING
LEGISLATORS AND VETERAN HOME
RESIDENTS.
THERE'S BEEN NOTICEABLE
IMPROVEMENT AT CAL THE UNDER
SECRETARY EMBOSSED YANNI. BUT WE
NEED STRUCTURAL CHANGE TO
SUSTAIN IMPROVEMENT BEYOND
CHANGES IN LEADERSHIP THIS BILL
WOULD GO A LONG WAY TO MAKING
THAT CHANGE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR DRIVE OF.
ANY TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
AND THE.
TESTIMONY IN.
BUT OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
COMMENTS.
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM. UP AND
NOW WE DO.
SO AFTER
TERRY NICHOLS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
IRWIN.
HERE VOEPEL YOU.
CHAVEZ.
DALY.
FRAZIER
GLORIA. MATHIS PRESIDENT.
MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK SILVA.
SOLACE.
WE HAVE QUORUM TO ROCK.
SO WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO TAKE A
MOTION.
DO WE HAVE A SECOND.
WE HAVE MOTION WE HAVE A SECOND
PLEASE VOTE.
NO AMENDMENTS THAT I'M AWARE OF.
TRY TO.
OTHER MOTION IS DUE PASSED A
ARE.
IRWIN.
IRWIN. AYE VOEPEL YES VOEPEL AYE
CHáVEZ.
CHáVEZ AYE DALY.
FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MURATSUCHI QUIRK SILVA
SOLACE.
SALAS AYE.
SEVEN ZERO.
THE BILL ITSELF.
I'M CATCHING ON TO THE STUFF.
IN A GREAT JOB.
SO.
A. B. THIRTY TO TWELVE.
Q. ADAM VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES AB THIRTY TO
TWELVE UPDATES AN EXPANSIVE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY AND
VETERAN'S CHO. TO INCREASE
MILITARY CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN
ORDER TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
SAFEGUARD OUR SERVICE MEMBERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. UNDER
CURRENT LAW MANY OF THE
PROTECTIONS IN CODE QUICKLY
EXPIRE AFTER SERVICEMEN A
SERVICE MEMBER LEAVES ACTIVE
DUTY AB THIRTY TO TWELVE WILL
HELP THOSE WHO STRUGGLE TO RE
INTEGRATE AFTER DEPLOYMENT BY
EXTENDING THE TIME FRAME.
THAT'S MEMBERS RECEIVE
PROTECTION FROM EVICTION AND NON
JUDICIAL FORECLOSURE UP TO A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS AFTER
LEAVING ACTIVE DUTY. THE BILL
ALSO ADDS THAT OUR STATE'S FULL
TIME ACTIVE COMPONENT PERSONNEL
RECEIVE EQUIVALENT PROTECTIONS
AS PROVIDED UNDER THE FEDERAL
SERVICE MEMBERS.
CIVIL RELIEF ACT.
IN ADDITION TO EXPANDING THE
REACH OF THOSE WHO WOULD BE
PROTECTED THE BILL ALSO
INCORPORATE CERTAIN PROTECTIONS
THAT ARE FOUND ONLY IN THE
FEDERAL SCR A. HAVE A COUPLE OF
WITNESS HEARS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CHARLES
HARVEY ON BEHALF OF THE OFFICE
OF ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE YET
ETCETERA. THOSE SPONSORED TO
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO TWELVE.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE MEMBER IRWIN FOR HER
LEADERSHIP. AND THIS AREA FOR
AUTHORING IS IMPORTANT BILL. I'M
EAGER TO SEE TWELVE THE SENSIBLE
CONSUMER PROTECTION MEASURE THAT
SEEKS TO EASE THE LEGAL AND
FINANCIAL BURDENS PLACED ON
CALIFORNIA SERVICE MEMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES BROUGHT ON BY THE
DEMANDS OF ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE.
THE BILL ALSO AIMS TO MAKE HOW
FREE A LOT LEAST AS PROTECTIVE
FOR SERVICE MEMBERS AS A
CORRESPONDENT FEDERAL LAW.
AS IT STANDS TODAY AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ONCE MENTION MANY THE
PROTECTIONS CURRENTLY AFFORDED A
TO OUR SERVICE MEMBERS UNDER
STATE LAW EXPIRE VERY QUICKLY
AFTER SERVICE NUMBER THESE
ACTIVE DUTY. AND IT'S
PROBLEMATIC COURSE BUT CAN'T
BECAUSE SERVICE MEMBERS NEED
TIME AFTER DEPLOYMENT TO.
REINTEGRATE AND MAY FACE
FINANCIAL DISTRESS DURING THIS
TRANSITION PERIOD.
AB THERE'S A TWELVE WOULD EXTEND
THE LENGTH OF TIME THAT SERVICE
MEMBERS RECEIVE BEARS
PROTECTIONS AS NOTED TACKLING
THOSE AGAINST DEFAULT JUDGMENT
AND NOT JUST FORECLOSURE. TO A
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS AFTER
LEAVING ACTIVE DUTY.
BILL ALSO INCORPORATES.
BEARS PROTECTIONS FOUND ONLY IN
THE US YOU ARE A. AYE INCLUDING.
RIGHTS FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE
LEASES EXPANDED PROTECTIONS
AGAINST LEAN SALES AND MAKING
CLEAR. THAT INTEREST ABOVE THE
SIX PERCENT CAP ON PRE SERVICE
OBLIGATIONS IS FORGIVEN AND NOT
MERELY TO FOR.
AND FINALLY OUR STATE LAWS
CURRENT MILITARY CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS APPLY ONLY TO
MEMBERS OF THE NATIONAL GUARD
AND RESERVE COMPONENTS.
THEY DO NOT THEIR BIKES INTO THE
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND.
ALL TIME MEMBERS OF THE ACTIVE
COMPONENTOF THE ARMED FORCES
WHO LIVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AB THIRTY TO TWELVE ADDRESSES
ITS MISSION BY MAKING THE STATE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AVAILABLE.
TO ALL MEMBERS OF THE ARMED
FORCES INCLUDING THESE ACT
COMPONENT PERSONNEL.
TAKEN TOGETHER THE PROPOSED
CHANGES IN THIS BILL GO A LONG
WAY TOWARD BETTER PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA SERVICE MEMBERS
INCLUDING DURING BOTH CRITICAL
POST DEPLOYMENT IN POST
SEPARATION PERIODS.
I'M JOINED HERE BY MY COLLEAGUE.
NICK ACRES MEMBER OF THE STATE
MILITARY RESERVE AND ALSO SENIOR
SEASON ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO
OVERSEES THE DOJ'S CONSUMER LAW
SECTION.
I HOPE YOUR BRIEF REMARKS AND IS
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
GET FILIBUSTERED HELD MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NICK
ACRES I'M THE SENIOR ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN CHARGE OF
THE CONSUMER LAS ACTION.
IN DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
MISTER HARVEY INDICATOR NAM ALSO
HAVE FIFTEEN YEARS OF SERVICE IN
THE STATE MILITARY RESERVE AS A
JUDGE ADVOCATE AND SPENT MUCH OF
THAT TIME PROVIDING LEGAL
ASSISTANCE.
TWO SOLDIERS AND AIRMEN AND
FAMILIES FROM THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD. AFTER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S CONSUMER LAW SECTION
HAS UNDERTAKEN A TARGETED EFFORT
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S MILITARY
VETERAN COMMUNITY.
THAT INCLUDES OUTREACH TRAINING
FOR ACTIVE DUTY AND RESERVE
COMPONENT JAG OFFICERS AND
MILITARY FINANCIAL COUNSELORS
AND TARGETED LAWSUITS AND
CRIMINAL PROSECUTIONS UNDER BOTH
MILITARY VETERANS CODE. AND
OTHER STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS.
A NUMBER OF THOSE CASES ARE THE
DIRECT RESULT OF REFERRALS FOR
OUR PARTNER IN THE MILITARY AND
VETERANS COMMUNITY AND
PARTICULARLY FROM NAVY AND
MARINE CORPS JUDGE ADVOCATES.
AND CIVILIAN LEGAL ASSISTANCE
ATTORNEYS AT NAVY BASE SAN DIEGO
CAMP PENDLETON AND MC RD.
I WOULD ALSO WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE US DEPARTMENT JUSTICE THE
STATE AND FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS AND OUR OTHER
FEDERAL STATE LOCAL AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS ON THESE
CASES.
AB THIRTY TO TWELVE IS A PRODUCT
OF THAT EXPERIENCE AND THE
INSIGHTS EXPERIENCE WE RECEIVED
BOTH FROM OUR PARTNERS IN THE
JAG LEGAL ASSISTANCE AND
MILITARY FINANCIAL COUNSELOR
COMMUNITY.
BUT ALSO FROM INDIVIDUAL
SERVICE MEMBERS AND MILITARY
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO CONTACTED OUR
OFFICE
AB THIRTY TO TWELVE IMPROVE
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING MILITARY
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN TWO
WAYS.
FIRST IT WOULD MAKE THE EXISTING
LOT MORE EFFECTIVE BY FILLING
GAPS THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED IN
THE COURSE OF OUR WORK. ENSURING
THEIR LAW REMAINS AS EFFECTIVE
THE FEDERALISTS YOU ARE A AND BY
EXTENDING THE DURATION THAT
SERVICE MEMBERS RECEIVE CERTAIN
PROTECTIONS INCLUDING
FORECLOSURE ADDICTION
REPOSSESSION PROTECTIONS. AFTER
THE TRANSITION BACK TO CIVILIAN
LIFE SECOND IT WOULD EXTEND
SELECTED PROTECTIONS WHICH
CURRENTLY ONLY COVER MEMBERS THE
GARDEN RESERVE. TO MEMBERS OF
THE ACTIVE COMPONENTS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS LEGISLATION AND
WOULD BE GLAD TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS.
CRAFTING THEIR MINDSET THREE BUT
THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS MANY
OF OUR CLIENTS HAVE NOT
RESPONDED THIS LEGISLATION YET
HOWEVER THEY HAVE SUPPORTED THIS
TYPE OF LEGISLATION IN THE PAST.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS KIRTLE LORNA
GREECE REPRESENTING MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF CHAPTERS. AND WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DON
HARPER IT WOULD REPRESENT THE
AMERICAN LEGION OF CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE A HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS LIVE IN THIS GREAT
STATE.
AND WE ARE SUPPORT THIS BILL
ASSURING AYE VOTE ON PLEASE
THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM.
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A ARMED.
BOB
YES SIR. I WOULD JUST. PUT IT IN
ENGLISH FOR ME.
MILITARY A YOUNG CORPORAL GETS
OUT AFTER SERVING FOUR YEARS IN
THE MARINE CORPS.
WHILE THEY'RE IN THE MILITARY
HAVE WHAT THE ARMY SAILORS ACT
TO PROTECT THEM FROM.
FORECLOSURE AND THINGS
BUT ONE STATE LEAVE LET'S SAY
HALF I HAVE.
.
CAR.
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE MY PAYMENTS
ON.
.
IT'S I BECAUSE I'M IN THIS
TRANSITION OF HAVING MONEY TO
KNOW MONEY. IS THAT WHAT THIS
BILL DOES PROTECT ME FOR THAT
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS THREE IMPART
YES IT DOES
AND AND IT PROVIDES A IT TAKES.
PRIDE YOU PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ONLY FOUND IN STATE
LAW THAT ONE OF THEM WOULD ALSO
BE DUE TO PROVIDE A GREATER
DURATION OF PROTECTION.
TO SOMEBODY WHO'S ETS AND GOT A
MARINE CORPS HAS THAT CAR ISN'T.
MAYBE IT'S ALL THE BEHIND ON
PAYMENTS IT IT'S NOT GOING TO
PROTECT THEM AGAINST ANY FORMER
REPOSSESSION BUT IT WILL MEAN
THAT A CREDITORS CAN HAVE GOT
QUIRK TO REPOSSESS THAT VEHICLE.
OF WHAT WE HAVE FOUND IT IS
TYPICALLY THAT WILL CAUSE A
CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE MARIN
THE FORMER THAT THE.
I'M A SAID FORMER MARINE I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT. THE MARINE
AND.
AND THEIR CREDITOR.
ABOUT.
POSSIBILITIES OF REFINANCING OR
OTHER OPTIONS FOR THAT VEHICLE
AND.
AND ESSENTIALLY SERGEI.
JUST A COOLING OFF PERIOD OF
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS ALLOWED.
MAKE OTHER ARRANGEMENTS WHY THEY
TRANSITION OUT OF THE MILITARY
TO GET ANOTHER JOB YES OR.
THIS IS ACTUALLY A REALLY GOOD
BILL IS PRETTY COOL. I MEAN
THEM.
I'M NOT A STRONG SUPPORT AT
WHICH I WAS BEEN CO AUTHOR ON IT
BUT DHEA. THIS IS A GOOD DEAL.
BE A LOCKER LIKE THANK YOUR
LUCKY BECAUSE ARENA THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING AFFORD FOR THE
FUNDS TO PASS AROUND A JOURNEY
GENERAL BUT. THIS DOES HAPPEN
ALL THE TIME FOR THE YOUNG
MILITARY TRANSITION NOT FOR
THAT.
THAT PERIOD OF TIME SO THIS IS A
GOOD DEAL THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
FORWARD.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
SO DO YOU TAKE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE SUGGESTED.
DID YOU NOT.
THERE WERE NO AMENDMENTS THAT
THERE ARE NO MOVES OKAY BECAUSE
I I KNOW IN IN THE ANNOUNCES
THAT I WAS TALKING ABOUT THERE
IS.
SUGGESTED FROM AROUND.
A FEW MINNESOTANS FINANCIAL
AFFAIRS AND SOME THINGS OF THAT
NATURE SO.
MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
MOMENT FOR DONNA.
THERE'S A FEW CHANGES THAT WILL.
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT GOING
FORWARD.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
JUST ONE QUICK COMMENT OF HAVING
BEEN DEPLOYED. ON VARIOUS
OCCASIONS. AND COMBAT DEPLOYED.
THEY ALWAYS TOLD US THAT WE WERE
PROTECTED.
AND THAT WAS OF GREAT COMFORT.
BECAUSE THOSE OF US
SERVICE MEMBERS AND HAD.
SPOUSES AND CHILDREN AND MOMS
AND DADS AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
YOU HAD TO MAKE SURE THAT CAR
PAYMENT WAS MADE THAT HOUSE
PAYMENT OR RENT PAYMENT WAS
MADE.
AND MANY TIMES IN THE MILITARY
KNOW IT'S HARD FOR ANY OF THE
MILITARY PEOPLE HERE TO BELIEVE
BUT SOMETIMES I MAKE MISTAKES
AND MESS UP YOUR ALLOTMENT.
AND THAT MONEY DOESN'T GET WHERE
IT'S POSTED GO.
THIS GOES A GREAT DISTANCE TO
PROTECT OUR MILITARY MEMBERS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS IS A
BEAUTIFUL THING.
APPRECIATE IT.
SO.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOVIE. MISSED
FRAZIER HAD MOVED IT EARLIER.
SO NOW WE HAVE TWO MOVEMENTS I'M
NOT GOING THERE FOR A JOKE.
PLEASE CLOSE.
DO YOU HAVE CLINICALLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
PLEASE CALL THE MOTION IS DO
PASSAGE JUDICIARY. IRWIN AYE
IRWIN AYE VOEPEL AYE VOEPEL AYE
CHáVEZ.
CHAVEZ IDEALLY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
NOW VOTING ONE WAY TO LOOK AT
THOSE AMENDMENTS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MERCY JEAN.
QUIRK SILVA. QUIRK SILVA AYE
SOLACE.
SO IF I.
EIGHT ZERO.
CONGRATULATIONS
A PASS FOR ALL OF US.
SO NOW WE CHAU PAUSE FOR A SHORT
MOMENT. AS THE.
CHAIRWOMAN COMES BACK.
RIGHT WE ARE GOING TO VOTE ON
THE.
.
CONSECTETUER.
AND THAT IS.
.
WEBER BERMAN. GLORIA AND I
COMMITTEE BILL.
BY CAN HAVE THE CLERK PLEASE TO
THE ROLL CALL.
IRWIN I IRWIN AYE VOEPEL. VOEPEL
AYE CHáVEZ CHáVEZ AYE DALY AYE
AYE DALY AYE FRAZIER. FRAZIER
AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I AM MATHIS.
MATHIS I MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUICKSILVER AYE SILAS. SALAS
AYE.
IT'S NINE ZERO.
RIGHT AND THEN.
YES WHAT GOOD CAN YOU FOR.
I THINK THERE IF YOU COULD READ
THROUGH THE.
BILLS AGAIN TO GIVE OUR OPINION
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD ON AND WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR FIVE
MORE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY IRWIN AYE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE RUBIO.
DALY AYE DALY AYE.
MURATSUCHI.
QUIKSILVER. QUICKSILVER I.
NINE ZERO.
GOOD WORK.
THE FARMERS.
CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND THEN HER TWO BILLS.
YEAH.
WE'LL HAVE CHRISTIAN GET AHOLD
OF YOU
.
AREA
SACRAMENTO.
SO I MAY HAVE.
GOT A SAFE FOR EVERYONE.
REYES YEAH.
ALRIGHT SO YOU GUYS
YEAH
HEY.
BECAUSE THE LAST.
YEAH.
OKAY SO WE HAD ABA.
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY IRWIN.
MURATSUCHI I MURATSUCHI I.
AB THIRTY TO TWELVE IRWIN MERCY
CHAIN AYE MURATSUCHI AYE. AND
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR UMMER
SU CHI. CHI MURATSUCHI AYE.
LEANN.
YEAH.
KAREN.
YEAH. MEETINGS ADJOURNED